let's talk about a new movement within
the Republican party and the question at
the end that I want to come back to is
is this a net good or a net bad for the
United States of America so Madison
cawthorne radical trumpist uh Republican
Congressman Madison cawthorne after just
16 months in office is already on his
way out he will be leaving in January he
lost his primary to a Challenger in
North Carolina on Tuesday and at least
part of the reason that Madison
cawthorne lost is that he became the
focus or the target
um of what we might call establishment
Republicans Madison cawthorne has had a
bunch of run-ins with the law a couple
of very high speed speeding and
potentially reckless driving incidents
involving his vehicle three times caught
bringing a firearm trying to bring
Firearms through TSA security and
bringing a gun to a school I'm sorry a
knife to a school council meeting of
some kind and then saying that he gets
invited to cocaine field orgies by other
members of Congress and it became very
clear that the Republican Party
establishment decided we're going after
this guy and they succeeded the group
that released some of the controversial
videos of Madison cawthorne say that
they are going to be targeting radical
trumpist lunatic congresswoman Lauren
bober next Business Insider reporting
Madison cawthorne foes who targeted him
with a damaging nude nude video say
Lauren bobert is next on their Hit List
the group that posted a viral sexually
explicit video of a nude Congressman
Madison cawthorne with another man in
bed is now focusing on Colorado
representative Lauren bobert for its
next takedown Insider has learned David
wheeler who's the co-founder of the
American muckrakers pack said to Insider
quote I think we're going to go after
Lauren bobert and Colorado in a similar
way
I think we're going to engage in that
race pretty quickly wheeler is a
Democrat his co-founder is unaffiliated
the group has Republicans among its
advisors wheeler said he's received
interesting information about the
Republican Firebrand bobert whose
primary against Republican state Senator
Don Quorum is on June 28th the
information is quote certainly not as
salacious as some of the cawthorne stuff
it deals instead with financial matters
and he didn't yet disclose more of it a
spokesperson for bobert did not
immediately respond to a request for
comment now as the article points out
previously Lauren bobert has also had
issues when it comes to campaign Finance
last year the AP reported that bobert
failed to disclose her husband's income
during the campaign in violation of
ethics and campaign Finance laws she
revealed her husband made nearly a
million dollars in 2019 and 2020 as a
consultant for an energy firm
um so what's the what's the question
that we have to ask here is this good or
bad for the country and what do I mean
by that well it's abundantly clear that
there are far less crazy Republicans out
there and that as a general thing
replacing a crazy Republican with a less
crazy Republican is good in a sense but
at the same time if the less crazy
Republicans can get things done versus
these wild trumpists who say a lot of
wacky things but don't get anything done
and sometimes even get kicked off of
committees is the country better off
with the crazier Republicans in office I
mean Marjorie Taylor green is a good
example Marjorie Taylor green was
stripped of her committee assignments
and essentially has no influence in the
House of Representatives okay you can
find some areas around the fringes where
maybe she is uh influencing someone but
very very little
um Matt Gates has some influence but
also he he's kind of a laughing stock if
you replace those people with you know
hard-working
um kind of buttoned up Republicans if
the if you replace them with people like
Mitt Romney who would would certainly
get fewer headlines but might be more
effective at getting legislation passed
or whipping votes or whatever the case
may be is the country better off or not
obviously when you take a very wide view
and you say well listen the if you take
eight outrageous lunatic Republicans and
replace them with people with whom you
know we kind of like we disagree on
taxes and abortion but they're not out
of their minds it sounds like that's an
improvement but at the same time if they
can actually accomplish things maybe
it's better to have the wackier people
in office I want to hear from you and
you know this is also a conversation
which we may be having in the context of
2024 because we talk about DeSantis
versus Trump if they both were to run
for the Republican nomination in 24
. DeSantis
is almost as crazy as Trump
but he's far more competent
and so in reality are we better off with
Trump even though he's more of a global
laughing stock I don't know this is a
prediction it's an it's a guess it's an
estimate it's not something we can say
for sure in advance but I want to hear
from you about it let me know your
thoughts one of our sponsors is called
privacy privacy is a totally free
service that I've been using for years
privacy lets me create virtual payment
cards with one click and when I use the
virtual card the money is taken out of
my bank account you can create multiple
cards delete them freeze them set a
spending limit on them let's say I'm
signing up for a free trial and it
requires a credit card privacy will
autofill a virtual card number and then
after signing up I can delete that
virtual card so I know I'm not going to
be charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say I'm
ordering food over the phone but I left
my wallet somewhere I don't have my real
credit card on me I can use a virtual
card on my privacy mobile app but really
the best part is you're not out there
exposing your real credit card number so
you're not as susceptible to data
breaches and identity theft privacy C is
a totally free service and you'll get
five bucks to spend when you go to
privacy.com Pacman the link is right
underneath this video